we begin with politics president-elect
joe biden continues to focus on the
coronavirus pandemic
as he prepares to take office january
20th meanwhile president trump is
continuing his fight today against the
election results hoping to stay
in office natalie brandt has the latest
for us from the white house
president-elect joe biden is today
holding a virtual round table with
health care workers on the front lines
of the coronavirus fight
the president-elect's coronavirus
advisory board says the trump
administration's refusal to begin the
transition process
is hurting its preparation you can't
start that
you know early enough you know we've
already lost nearly 250 000 lives
to this pandemic you know we owe it to
the public
to work together as closely as possible
as efficiently as possible
president trump's own covid task force
now shows 47 states are in the red zone
for new cases
the task force calls the spread of the
virus aggressive
and unrelenting this comes as president
trump continues to fight the election
results
claiming widespread voter fraud without
proof on tuesday he fired the homeland
security director responsible for
protecting the vote
from cyber attacks you should have
confidence in the integrity of the
process
christopher krebs told cbs news by phone
he expected to be fired and has no
regrets
last week he issued a statement saying
there is no evidence that any voting
system deleted or lost
votes changed votes or was in any way
compromised
i don't know if it was a partisan agenda
a personal grievance what it was
but it definitely seemed to be animated
by something and it seemed to go
directly at this president and
legitimate claims that he's pursuing in
court
in wayne county michigan which includes
detroit republican members of the board
of canvassers initially blocked
certifying the vote there before
changing their minds and certifying
results showing president-elect biden
as the winner natalie brand cbs news the
white house